historien enseignant chercheur ou bien
curieux ont tous genres n'importe qui
peut consulter et utiliser les archives
créée en 1794 les archives
départementales des yvelines vieux
souvent méconnus regorge d'informations
pour qui voudrait se plonger dans
l'histoire c'est le cas de marc vigier
inspecteur académique à la retraite mon
travail de recherche actuellement je
travaille sur la délinquance forestière
dans la forêt de rambouillet au xviiie
siècle
c'est à dire à l'époque de cette forêt
relever du duché perry et donc la forêt
de rambouillet que vous pouvez toujours
aujourd'hui admiré dont vous pouvez
profiter
c'est exactement celle du duché pereda
l'époque plusieurs jours par semaine
depuis le mois d'octobre
marc vigier étudie décrypte et analyse
des documents
cela doit lui permettre de publier une
étude scientifique dans l' ouvrage de la
collection mémoire et documents de
lashari la société d'histoire et
d'archéologie de rambouillet et des
yvelines dont il est membre bénévole
vous avez des kilomètres et des
kilomètres de cartons d'archives/reuters
dans les magasins qui semblait étage est
par exemple le fonds de la maîtrise des
eaux et forêt de rambouillet au xviiie
siècle
c'est à peu près de 150 cartons archives
et dans chaque quart-temps d'archivés
compter à peu près un millier folio la
cote c'est la série b c'est le volume
2246 de la série b donc ça vous indique
votre suivi ont déjà 2246 parent c'est
qu'on a c'est intéressant on fait comme
lorsqu'on fait sa maîtrise ou son
doctorat et c c'est à dire que ou lis
très attentivement les inventaires pour
savoir très précisément ce qui vous
intéresse
et puis après ça après ça on va à la
pêche et ça peut durer longtemps
sans ce lieu gardien de la mémoire ce
retraité ne pourrait publier
prochainement son étude pour lui
l'archivage est nécessaire je pourrais
pas passer ceux ci avaient passé
documentation il n'y aura pas de sujet
que j'ai choisi ce sujet
parce que je vis moi même en lisière de
forêt dans mouillé mais j'ai choisi ce
sujet tout simplement parce que j'ai
vérifié qu'il était très table j'ai
publié plusieurs livres j'ai publié une
centaine d'articles scientifiques c'est
énorme et je m'en lasse pas un outil
indispensable donc et que le chercheur
connaît bien ce n'est évidemment pas la
première fois qu'il se plonge dans les
entrailles de la mémoire il vit noise
plus anciennement lorsque j'étais
inspecteur d'académie en responsabilité
c'est grâce à la documentation que j'ai
pu trouver ici que j'ai rédigé un petit
ouvrage sur l'histoire d'accueil
versailles
on peut satisfaire ici une curiosité
quasiment illimitées et une curiosité
toujours aussi affûté pour ce retraité
qui compte bien continuer à passer son
temps à fouiller la mémoire des archives
départementales